hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute richtig hübsche
baby cupcakes machen und zwar könnt ihr
diese backen zum beispiel für eine baby
shower party also so eine partie die man
vor geburt des kindes macht oder ihr
könnt sie backen wenn ihr eure
schwangerschaft verkünden wollt wenn
eure freundin schwanger ist oder wenn
ihr sie einfach mal so zur geburt
verschenken wollte ich habe bereits
meine muffins vorgebacken und zwar habe
ich hier einmal schoko muffins und
zitronen muffins das rezept dazu findet
ihr in meinem martin grundrezept video
das verlinke ich euch hier oder auch in
der infobox unten unter dem video und
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal was ich
für die dekoration brauche
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier etwas
modelle schokolade deko job in weiß blau
und rosa ich habe hier ein paar
ausstecher also hier habe ich so ganz
süßes baby ausstecher aber ich zeige
euch auch noch alternativen und brauche
jetzt einfach ein paar rechtecke hier
habe ich so blümchen ausstecher runde
ausstecher zahlen buchstaben und in ein
paar blümchen sterne und herzchen und
ich arbeite jetzt gleichauf dieser
silikon matte da klebt nämlich nichts
und ich brauche auch eventuelle hier
dieses schaumstoff pet das ist
eigentlich wie blüten und blumen gedacht
und so ein paar kleine werkzeuge und
zuerst stelle ich jetzt mal den
hintergrund her also sondern untergrund
ich möchte den aufleger als gleich
trocknen lassen und später dann auf die
muffins draufsetzen mit einer creme
drunter und deswegen nehme ich auch
modelle schokolade denn die kann ich
auch auf sahne krems drauf setzen ohne
dass sie eben schmilzt wenn ihr nämlich
von dort benutzt dann müsste ebenen
anderen untergrund nehmen wir zb kanal
zuerst muss man jetzt die modelle
schokolade weich kneten das geht ganz
gut geklebt auch nicht und dann rolle
ich sie mit einem ausstieg aus
als nächstes nehme ich mir jetzt hier
diesen blumen ausstecher und auch einen
runden ausstecher und diesen etwa so
groß wie der muffin also passt dann auch
super als aufleger und stellt mir damit
eben die kreise aus
jetzt beginne ich mit dem ersten motiv
ich lasse die untergründe einfach etwas
an trocknen und fest werden und zwar
möchte ich ein baby body machen
hier habe ich jetzt einen ausstecher
aber ich zeige euch auch gleich die
variante ohne aussteller
die aussteller haben hier so eine präge
funktion also erst ausstechen und dann
rein drücken
und jetzt kann man es umsetzen
und jetzt noch die variante ohne
ausstecher dafür schneidet ihr hier oben
gerade ab und macht da so ein rechteck
daraus geht am besten mit einem lineal
oder einem anderen karten gegenstand
dann habe ich hier so einen rechteckigen
ausstecher
jetzt sieht es aus wie ein t shirt und
jetzt nehmt ihr euch noch eine
spritztour zum beispiel oder an anderen
runden gegenstand und könnt ihr den
halsausschnitt ausstechen und unten die
beine
und damit ist auch richtig hübsch
aussieht steche ich noch ein weißes herz
aus und klebt es noch darauf
und mit seinem präge werkzeug könnt ihr
hier noch ein paar nette einprägen
als nächstes möchte hier ein paar
lätzchen formen auch da nimmt die
einfachen runde aus städte oder zum
beispiel ein deckel von einer flasche
und mit einem kleineren ausstecher
steche ich das jetzt hier so bis hin
versetzt aus
und hier habe ich schon mal mit nem
blumen ausstechen der weiße blume
ausgestochen
die träge ich jetzt vorher auch einmal
eins geht am besten auf der schaumstoff
matte und dann kann ich die auch direkt
drauf setzen
als nächstes brauche ich jetzt einen
kinderwagen und ich habe jetzt hier
unter der modelle schokolade unter das
silikon mattes enquete denn bei mir in
der küche ist es sehr warm und die
modelle schokolade wird dann einfach zu
weich
jetzt stelle ich mir hier einen kreis
aus ich zeige sich erst noch ohne
ausstecher und dann eben mit
dann schneide ich mir da oben etwas vom
kreis weg
nehme mir dann die weiße modelle
schokolade und sticht damit kleinere
kreise für die reifen aus und wenn ihr
mal was kleben bist und so nicht hält
könnte etwas zucker kleber benutzen
und mit so einem blumen ausstecher
könnte jetzt noch die abdeckung machen
bei den kinderwagen
da braucht man nämlich jetzt einfach nur
so ein vierter
und zu sehen jetzt die mit einem
ausstecher aus
als nächstes mache ich jetzt noch so ein
kleines baby in seinem wickeltisch und
dafür habe ich mir schon mal ein
rechteck oder quadrat ausgeschnitten mit
6 auf 6 zentimetern und das trägt ich
jetzt hier noch mit diesem präge
werkzeug
und dann habe ich jetzt etwas modell der
schokolade mit rosa weiß und gelb
gemischt als beleg gelbe
lebensmittelfarbe dazu gegeben
einfach zwei drei tropfen dann kommt
nämlich dieser hautton raus dann nehmt
ihr euch ein kleines stück vom google
drückt die kugel so ein bisschen flach
dann kommt eine etwas kleinere kugel mit
rein dass wir die nase
hier stelle ich mir noch den schnuller
aus mache ich zwei kreise in
verschiedenen kulissen
und mit einem schwarzen lebensmittel
stift kommen da ist auch die augen mit
drauf
das tuch muss oben gedreht werden da
kommt etwas kleber mit rein dann der
kopf und damit runden nicht so flach
aussieht einfach so ein bisschen von der
modelliermasse und jetzt wird es einfach
nur noch zugeklappt
als nächstes möchte ich jetzt eine
kleine babyflasche machen
ich habe ich mir schon eine rolle
vorbereitet mit weißer modelle
schokolade und schneidet die einmal
zurecht so etwa 15 cm lang und auch die
rolle habe ich vorher kurz aufs eis
gelegt damit sie einfach etwas fester
wird
und das gleiche habe ich jetzt hier auch
mit blau und rosa gemacht dass schneide
ich jetzt ein kleines stück ab
die werden dann da drauf geklebt
und mit der hautfarbenen modelle
schokolade vor mich vorne noch den drink
aufsatz
und dann kommen hier einfach nur noch
ein paar streifen auf
als nächstes zeige ich euch wie man
einen schnuller macht und dafür habe ich
schon mal zwei kreise ausgestochen
und da stecke ich jetzt mit so einer
tülle noch zwei löcher rein
dann nehme ich mir wieder hier von der
hautfarbenen modelliermasse ein kleines
stück vorne kugeln und die wird dann
gerade hier mit den fingern so ein
bisschen länglich geformt
und dann aufgeklebt
ich mache hier noch die hintergründe
fertig und zwar stehe ich hier mit einer
lok hülle so kleine löcher aus dann
sieht es nämlich aus wie so ein kleines
tischdecken und die setzt sich dann auf
die bereits ausgesprochenen hintergründe
auf genauso wie die runden die ich auch
noch vorbereitet habe
und für das letzte deckchen nehme ich
jetzt meinen alligator schneider und
zwar den mit den 1 cm würfeln und den
missbrauch jetzt einfach und drückt da
jetzt hier dieses muster rein nur ganz
leicht und dann könnt damit so einem
ball werkzeug oder einem anderen
werkzeug jede noch so kleine punkte ein
stechen
ich habe hier noch ein paar buchstaben
ausgestochen und die sätze ich jetzt
auch noch drauf
und jetzt setzt sich noch die dekoration
und auf die aufleger drauf und bei
bedarf könnte die auch ankleben
die dekoration ist jetzt soweit fertig
und ich habe es jetzt auch inhalten tag
jetzt mal stehen lassen und liegen
lassen damit sie bisschen an trocknet
dann werden nämlich die elemente auch
etwas fester und jetzt habe ich hier ja
bereits meine vor gebackenen muffins
einmal schoko und einer zitrone und die
bespritzte ich jetzt die hellen mit
einer leckeren frisch käsecreme mit
frischkäse sahne creme und die dunklen
mit peter carl schmitt mit der
schokoladen sahne und die rezepte dafür
verlinke ich euch auch in der infobox da
habe ich ein extra video dazu
jetzt können die einzelnen deko elemente
einfach nur noch drauf gesetzt werden
so sehen jetzt die fertigen baby
cupcakes aus und ihr solltet ihr auf
jeden fall im kühlschrank aufbewahren
damit die creme nicht weiß wird und die
kühlschranktemperatur macht auch dieser
modelle schokolade nichts deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier auch bei dem rezept
modelle schokolade genommen denn ich
kann sie ja auch ganz normale sahne
creme setzen ohne dass sie weich wird
wenn ihr das ganze mit von der macht
also mit von dort dekoriert dann müsst
ihr die creme etwas abändern und eine
garage nehmen die ihr vorher aber nicht
auf schlag was ihr könnt ja nicht so auf
spritzen mit dem spritzbeutel weil die
viel zu feucht ist und die dieser von
dong einfach etwas feucht wird und dann
einfach auseinander läuft auf jeden fall
ist es hier meine idee und ich finde es
ganz hübsch wenn man sie zum beispiel
verschenken möchte wenn jemand gerade
ein baby bekommen hat aber das hatte ich
alles schon erzählt und dieses genaue
rezept gibt es noch mal auf meinem blog
nachzulesen auf jolie.de mit allen
anleitungen mit allen rezepten und die
videos verlinkt ihr euch wie gesagt alle
in meiner infobox ich freue mich schon
wieder aufs nächste mal bis dann tschüss
hat der händler noch nicht